so what's the show about oh man
that's hard brother what's up
hey what are you doing this is john with
the dr john dolone show what's happening
we say the show's about mental health
and relationships how to live a well
life listen take yourself out to dinner
it is rare that i hear a new one and
that's a new one so well done so the
show can go anywhere at any time on
today's show we talked to a woman who's
in love with a hypochondriac and it's so
hard to a dad who's trying to teach body
positivity to his young daughters
dealing with big t trauma and family
history to a sister whose brother-in-law
has screwed up everything and we talked
to a young mom whose husband keeps
making sexual jokes around the kids whoa
stay tuned
people ask me all the time man how'd you
learn how to do this to take those calls
and get to it real fast and make some
jokes and bring the room up the truth is
i've been doing that a long long time i
got two phds i've been doing this for a
couple of decades and i'm still learning
every day still trying to figure it out
as i walk alongside people
the guests are incredible they're
fantastic so it's fun to have guests man
who've done a bunch of fancy stuff i
love it the heart of this show is
callers just like you
yeah i mean my dad was angry growing up
he never
that's all you're going to say it's like
that's all you got to say so i gotta say
your dad is intentionally disregarding
your requests for how you can best be
loved yeah and that disregard is
violence i don't want to try to take the
kids from her but i'm also feel like i'm
responsible for their safety as their
dad and all right so listen listen to me
carefully okay
yeah your your instinct is right and i
heard you say it at the end there and i
love your heart i don't want to take
these kids from their mother
and what i would say to you is she is
screaming for somebody to please take
these kids from me before i hurt them
have you ever heard me lie to anybody
no
okay i'm not starting today it's not
your fault
you cannot do life alone you can't heal
from hurt on your own and that's what
this show's for man and if you will put
in the work you'll give me a call if
you'll do the hard work you will change
your family tree and it starts with you
deciding you're worth being well
[Music]
that's not i missed the melody i think
you missed something we'll just leave it
at that
this is the john delony show what's up